el velorio de Pelé debe durar 24 horas
desde las 10 de la mañana personalidades
del deporte de la política incluso
jueces de la Corte Suprema están
acudiendo a Vila belmiro en Santos para
despedirse del rey del fútbol llama la
atención que en la cola hay ciudadanos
Anónimos de todas las edades que hablan
de pelea con mucho cariño incluso
jóvenes que no vivieron su época dorada
pero le admiran por su yogo bonito Por
su forma increíble de jugar al fútbol es
por eso que hoy el presidente de la FIFA
ha pedido a todos los estados miembros
que dediquen al menos un estadio en sus
países al Astro del fútbol aquí en
Brasilia Pelé también ha estado muy
presente ayer en la investidura del
presidente Luis Ignacio Silva que le
dedicó Un minuto de silencio al jugador
y también al paparatzinger hoy Lula se
prevé que llegue también a Santos para
participar del Velorio y mañana del
entierro antes se reunirá con varios
jefes de estado como el rey de España y
los presidentes de Argentina Ecuador y
Bolivia